let's start with the situation with
vaccinations there's obviously been a
massive government push to get it um i i
guess that continues well yeah since we
learned about omicron our strategy has
been to buy time time to assess it and
time to build our defenses and whilst
there's still a lot of uncertainty
around this new variant we do know that
our very best form of defense is
vaccination now sadly when we look at
the latest hospital emissions a
disproportionate number of those people
are unvaccinated and when you look at
those requiring the most intensive care
even more are unvaccinated we know that
two vaccines aren't quite enough but
you're having three doses is excellent
protection the nhs has done a fantastic
job especially over the last few weeks
working with the military with
volunteers in offering more and more
vaccinations across the country over 30
million people boosted 75 percent of
eligible adults now boosted that's more
than any other country in europe but we
still need more people to to come
forward and and we've got 1.5 million
slots available over the next few days
across england it it's never been so
easy to go and get whether it's your
first vaccine shot your second or your
booster shot so can i please say to
people please do come forward get
vaccinated protect yourselves protect
your loved ones and protect your
community we'll talk restrictions in a
second but there was this big government
push to get
pretty much the country vaccinated by
the end of the year is is that no longer
possible do you think is that not enough
people coming forward to get those
people that should be vaccinated well as
a country when it comes to vaccinations
we've done very well over 90 percent of
adults have had at least one uh vaccine
shot our focus because of this new
variant has been on booster shots over
the last few weeks and and we said about
three weeks ago that we want to make
sure that every adult in the country has
a credible opportunity to get their
booster shot by the end of the year and
that commitment will be met so 75
percent of eligible adults already
boosted but we want to get that to 100
and so we want people uh to come forward
there's plenty of slots there's plenty
of availability and whilst the nhs is
doing a brilliant job we need people to
come forward and protect themselves and
their community
we've been told today that prime
minister i'm sure yourself have been
talking to people getting the latest
figures and the latest data
looking at restrictions in england what
is the latest on that well of course we
we look at the data on a daily basis
that hasn't changed over the christmas
period uh but there will be no further
measures uh before the new year we won't
be taking any further measures of course
people should remain cautious as we
approach new year celebrations and you
know take a lateral flow test that makes
sense celebrate outside if you can have
some ventilation indoors if you can
please remain cautious and when we get
into the new year of course we will see
then whether we do need to take any
further measures but nothing more until
then at least
why take that decision because the new
year is a big time a lot of people
mixing alcohol involved you know dangers
of passing on a variant like this we've
seen you know the the restrictions in
the other developed nations why not in
england why take that decision well we
look at the data on a daily basis we get
the very best advice for our scientists
nhs friends and we put all that uh
together and whilst of course yes there
is still a lot of uncertainty around
this variant it is growing fast we think
some 90 of cases now across uh england
are this new omicron variant so it shows
you just how quickly it has spread
we have had news in in recent days that
it's milder now that in itself isn't
good news enough that's good news but we
know that it spreads very rapidly so we
have to set that news against that but
whilst we should all absolutely remain
cautious we don't think there's any need
for any further measures uh until the
new year but of course we will keep that
under review if people are in scotland
northern ireland wales they've had more
restrictions quite stringent
restrictions in some places they're
seeing the same data
why
in england is it not happening while it
is there it's for it's for each country
that makes up the united kingdom to
decide uh how it wants to go forward so
for example in england uh we decided
back in july that we would open up in
the summer i think we look back now that
has been the right decision uh we are
very very focused on vaccinations uh
anti-virals program has started as the
uk we now have almost 5 million courses
of antivirals that's more per head than
any other country in europe we are
testing more than any country in europe
and that helps us to keep us safe so
vaccinations antivirals testing regime
and and cautious behavior that we're
seeing people's changing in habits as
we've seen over christmas this will all
help to limit spread but of course we
will watch carefully what is happening
in the hospitals we're working to build
hospital capacity as well and continue
to do that but we'll watch the situation
very carefully and should in the future
we need to act of course we won't
hesitate to do so
just on the restrictions that were
brought in wearing masks in certain
places i happened to be
working in a football ground covering a
football match yesterday a huge
percentage of people didn't wear masks
more than 40 000 people a grand didn't
wear masks but almost ignoring the
advice ignoring the rules
is that a problem are people
so sick of covert so sick of this so
sick of following rules that they are
not doing it now whatever you say
they're not going to follow i think
certainly the vast vast majority of
people
are following the rules they're they're
being very sensible even you know their
own behavior when it's not about rules
but just uh looking at the very latest
guidance about things like ventilation
things like you're taking a free lateral
flow test if you're especially going to
meet someone who's vulnerable it might
be an older an older relative you might
be visiting a care home and these are
the kind of measures that are really
helping and make a difference but the
biggest difference we can all make is to
get vaccinated as i say there's 1.5
million slots available across england
over the next few days there's never
been a better opportunity to get
vaccinated protecting yourself your
family and your loved ones just finally
royal college of nursing saying they're
concerned because of the rates and the
spread and how many people are are
getting the variant that staff shortages
are a real problem they're they're
struggling with numbers
how bad is that situation looks that
staffing is a challenge and the
absenteeisms and rates that we're seeing
throughout the nhs particularly london
are relatively high at the moment and
like in any other sector of the economy
in the in in the country uh people are
having to rightly self-isolate if they
become infected that is having an impact
but some of the recent changes that
we've made especially around the
self-isolation rule of moving to ten
days to seven days as long as you had
negative lateral flow deaths in day six
and day seven that is really helping at
this point but it's something we're
watching very closely and we keep it
under review